THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S
ANGLE.
THERE WAS A LAUGH OUT LOUD
MOMENT THIS MORNING AS JOE BIDEN
MADE HIS PRESIDENTIAL PITCH ON
ABC'S "GOOD MORNING AMERICA."
THERE WERE SEVERAL NICE LEPERS
BUT I'M TRYING TO RESTRAIN
MYSELF HERE.
CHECK THIS OUT.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT HAS A
MOTTO, MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
DO YOU HAVE ONE?
>> MAKE AMERICA MORAL AGAIN.
MAKE AMERICA RETURN TO THE
ESSENCE OF WHO WE ARE, THE
DIGNITY OF THE COUNTRY AND
PEOPLE CHANGING OUR PEOPLE WITH
DIGNITY.
AND THIS GOD AWFUL DIVISION THAT
IS BEING TAKEN TO SEPARATE
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: I'M NOT SURE WHY SHE
HAD TO KEEP INTERJECTING THERE.
[LAUGHS]
JOE BIDEN WILL MAKE IS MORAL
AGAIN?
IS THAT THE SAME JOE BIDEN WAS
DRIVEN OUT OF THE RACE YEARS AGO
AMIDST CHARGES OF PLAGIARISM?
IS THIS THE SAME CATHOLIC JOE
WHO HAS EVOLVED AWAY FROM HIS
FACE?
HE WAS ONCE PRO-LIFE AND EVEN
VOTED FOR ABORTION BANDS 1997.
ONLY WHEN THAT BAN WAS UPHELD IN
2007 BY THE SUPREME COURT,
CATHOLIC JOE EVOLVED.
>> WITH HIS COURT DATE IT TOOK
THAT DECISION AND PUT A TROJAN
HORSE THERE THREW ACTUALLY
DISHONEST REASONING, A LADY
GROUND WORK GROUNDWORK FOR
UNDOING ROE V. WADE.
THAT IS THE DANGER OF THIS
DECISION.
THE RATIONALE OFFERED TO JUSTIFY
I THINK THE NEXT STEP THEY WILL
TAKE.
>> Laura: SEVERAL BISHOPS HAVE
DENIED HIM COMMUNION TO HIS
RABID ACT OF THE SEA.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT UNTIL
TODAY AND NOW HE IS LECTURING US
ON MORALITY?
WHAT DOES HE MEAN BY HIS
MORALITY?
>> THE DIGNITY OF THE COUNTRY
AND PEOPLE AND TREATING OUR
PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY.
THIS IS ABOUT RESTORING DIGNITY,
THE DIGNITY OF WORK.
>> Laura: DIGNITY?
HE IS A FUN PERSON.
I'M SURE HE IS A NICE GUY.
AT AGE 76 IS COMING ACROSS AS
KIND OF A RAMBLING LEFT SCHOOL
VERSION OF OBAMA.
WE KNOW HOW
MUCH DIGNITY HE BELIEVES THOSE
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS DESERVE
DESERVED, OBAMA.
>> IN PENNSYLVANIA, A LOT THE
MIDWEST.
EACH ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
THAT SOMEHOW THESE COMMITTEES
WILL REGENERATE AND THEY HAVE
NOT.
THEY CLAIM TO DEMOCRATS OR
RELIGION OR PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE
THAT
>> Laura: NOW WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BELIEVE THAT THOSE BETTER
KLINGER'S WILL LOOK TO RAMBLING
JOB
TO RETAKE THEIR DIGNITY?
I'VE BEEN FEELING MOST AMERICANS
DON'T LOOK TO THE GOVERNMENT TO
DELIVER THEIR MORALITY OR THEIR
DIGNITY.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WANT TO BE
LEFT ALONE TO LIVE THEIR LIVES
IN PEACE AND MAYBE HAVE A FEW
EXTRA BUCKS IN THEIR POCKET.
THE ARGUMENT HE IS TRYING TO
MAKE IS I AM NICER THAN MEAN OLD
TRUMP SO VOTE FOR ME.
I THINK YOU COULD CALL THIS THE
MAYOR PETE OF FACT.
HE SAW PETE BUTTIGIEG AS
MOUNTING RELIGIOUS PLATITUDES
WHILE ADVOCATING RADICAL
POLICIES AND HE THOUGHT, I CAN
LITERALLY DO THAT BETTER THAN HE
CAN.
THE TRUTH IS THIS IS A CANDIDATE
AND A PARTY IN A TOUGH SPOT HER
HERE.
POLITICO REPORTED THIS,
DEMOCRATS SWEAT TRUMPS THE
ECONOMY.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A ROBUST
NATIONAL MESSAGE RIGHT NOW, YOU
THINK?
IF YOU LISTEN CAREFULLY THE 2020
DEMOCRATS AREN'T MAKING THE CASE
THAT THEIR IDEAS ARE GOING TO
GROW THE ECONOMY FASTER THAN
TRUMP OR LEAD TO BIGGER WAGE
INCREASES WERE LOWER
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS.
INSTEAD THEY BECOME THE
SELF-APPOINTED, SELF-ANOINTED
LEADERS OF A NEW LIBERAL MORAL
MAJORITY.
>> WE NEED TO RESTORE THAT MORAL
FABRIC.
>> THIS IS A MORAL ISSUE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE ON A REFLECTION
OF OUR VALUES.
>> I'M TIRED OF THAT.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF MORAL OF
DEJA THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
FORGOTTEN WHAT THEY HAVE SHOWN
AMERICA LATELY.
AFTER SPENDING TWO YEARS
DEFAMING PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
CALLING HIM A TRAITOR, DEMOCRATS
ARE PROVEN WRONG IN THE MUELLER
REPORT AND YET THEY REFUSED TO
APOLOGIZE.
HOW IS THAT MORAL?
ON THE ISSUE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, DEMOCRATS ARE LYING
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT A
FULL-BLOWN CRISIS AT HER BORDER.
NANCY PELOSI WON'T WORK WITH HIM
ON THE ISSUE JUST BECAUSE OF
POLITICS.
HOW IS THAT MORAL?
THINGS ARE PRETTY EITHER FOR
JOE BIDEN AS THE WE ARE MORE
MORAL THAN TRUMP PARTY.
WHERE ARE THEY CALLING FOR THE
RESIGNATION OF THE CHICAGO
PROSECUTOR?
ALLOWED JUSSIE SMOLLETT TO WALK
FREE OR HOW ABOUT THE LIBERAL
BALTIMORE MAYOR ON THE BRINK OF
RESIGNATION TONIGHT.
A FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS ON HER
FINANCIAL DEALINGS.
WE MUST'VE MISSED A JOE'S
COMMENTS ON HER.
MORALITY IS JUST BUSTING OUT ALL
OVER AT THE VIRGINIA STATE HOUSE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A SITTING
GOVERNOR AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
BOTH WITH BLACK FACE PROBLEMS.
LET'S NOT FORGET MR. MORALITY
HIMSELF, A DEMOCRAT JUSTIN
FAIRFAX, I WILL LET ONE OF HIS
EXCUSE WAS TOLD THAT STORY.
>> I BROKE DOWN INTO TEARS.
I FEEL GUILTY.
>> WHY DO YOU FEEL GUILTY?
>> HAPPENED TO HER AFTER IT
HAPPENED TO ME AND HAD I HAD THE
STRENGTH FOR THE COURAGE TO SAY
SOMETHING IN 2,000, MAYBE IT
NEVER WOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO HE
HER.
>> Laura: THAT IS HARD TO
WATCH BUT IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THE STORIES AND
REMEMBER SOME DEMOCRATS DID URGE
THE MEN TO STEP ASIDE BUT YOU
NOTICED HOW QUIET IT HAS GOTTEN
LATELY?
IF IT HAD BEEN A REPUBLICAN, ANY
OFFICIAL DEMOCRATS WOULD NOT
HAVE RESTED UNTIL THOSE MEN WERE
DRIVEN OUT OF OFFICE.
CLEARLY DEMOCRATS BITTER ABOUT
HIS WRONG ECONOMY, THEIR
DESPERATE AND THEY ARE CLINGING
TO THEIR MORALITY NARRATIVE.
THERE IS ANOTHER PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE ALSO BECOME THE PARTY
OF INFANTICIDE, WAS THE GOVERNOR
WHO WELL NOT AN BLACKFACE
EXPLAINED THE CHRIS LEE PROCESS
THAT HE SOUGHT TO EXPAND UNDER
HIS STATE LAW.
>> IF A MOTHER IS IN LABOR I CAN
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
THE INFANT WOULD BE DELIVERED,
THE INFANT WOULD BE KEPT
COMFORTABLE.
THE INFANT WOULD BE RESUSCITATED
IF THAT IS WHAT THE MOTHER OF
THE FAMILY TO DESIRED AND A
DISCUSSION WOULD ENSUE BETWEEN
THE POSITIONS ON THE MOTHER.
>> Laura: DAYS LATER THE
ASSEMBLY PASSED A BILL
LEGALIZING THIS UNDER
CRIMINALIZING LATE-TERM
ABORTIONS.
THE REACTION?
>> THE BILL HAS PASSED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THAT MY FRIENDS IS A MORAL
STANDING OVATION.
HIS PEOPLE OF THE MORAL
EXEMPLARS, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO GET OFF THEIR
MORAL HIGH HORSES OR THEY WILL
GET BLOCKED RIGHT OFF.
IT IS IMMORAL TO CONDEMN AND
JUDGE A MAN WHO LIKE ALL OF US
IS FLAWED BUT WHO GAVE UP A
REALLY CUSHY LIFE TO FIGHT HARD
EVERY DAY FOR PROSPERITY AND
SECURITY FOR ALL AMERICANS AND
HE HAS DONE MORE FOR THE CAUSE
OF LIFE THAN ANY PRESIDENT IN MY
LIFETIME AND I WORKED FOR
RONALD REAGAN.
THIS RECORD OF TRUMP IS
STUNNING, EVEN WITH ALL THE
RANCHERS THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TRIED TO JAM.